Musik Einen wunderschönen guten Tag, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO, mir gegenüber sitzt wie immer Stefan Tietze. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge, Flo und den Bild ist mir gegenüber, herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren Ausgabe einer Folge wie jeder anderen, Folge 300 des Podcast UFOs. Ganz normale Folge, macht euch keine Sorgen, keinen Druck, ihr habt euch völlig umsonst den Wrack angezogen. Naja, man kann ja, bei Geburtstagen muss man sich auch, muss man sich entscheiden, will man feiern, will man den Runden feiern, will man es nicht. Und nicht, wenn man es respektieren, wenn Leute ihren Runden Geburtstag nicht feiern wollen. Absolut, ich finde sowieso, das ist ein absoluter Geburtstagsterror, viele Leute wollen ihren Geburtstag nicht feiern, das ist ein Tag wie der andere, und das schätze ich und das respektiere ich, deswegen macht das auch. Was heisst auch 300 eines Podcasts? Es ist ja jetzt nicht, dass wir jetzt genau vor 300 Wochen angefangen hätten oder sowas. Es ist ja, wir haben ja zwischendurch keine, wir haben ja nicht aufgenommen, damals hatten wir noch sehr unregelmäßige Abstände, jetzt sind wir bei Folge 300 angekommen. Spart euch die Glückwünsche, ich würde lieber das Datum feiern, wo wir uns kennengelernt haben. Ja, das fände ich schön. Oder das Datum, wo wir zum ersten Mal aufgenommen haben. Was wir natürlich auch feiern und was so ein bisschen schon Galacharakter angestartet hat,
war natürlich Florian und sein fantastisches Intro mit unseren Lieblingsbläsern von Druckluft,
die mal wieder absolut abgeliefert haben.
Das war Druckluft. Ich habe es nämlich im Klang erkannt.
Man erkennt diesen Original-Druckluft-Sound, man erkennt es einfach.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen, jetzt geht es dazu.
Okay.
Wir haben Zeit.
Du musst jetzt nicht jetzt.
Eine Stunde Zeit, ich will einige Sachen entgegen.
Alles klar, wir haben heute viel vor.
Vielen Dank. Letzte Woche habe ich nämlich gesagt, wie wäre es denn, wenn man mal das Jurassic Park Intro auf, dieses Jurassic Park Theme aufgrund der neuen Ereignisse und den neuen Dingen, die man über Dinos erfährt,
nicht mal auf Moll umkomponiert.
Es ist mittlerweile kein Lächelthema mehr.
Dinosaurier sind ein trauriges Thema, es ist ein Downer,
und das muss eigentlich auch wieder gespiegelt werden musikalisch.
Und das hat Florian fantastisch gemacht mit seiner Moll-Version.
Können wir das auch mal hören?
Ist so schön.
Okay.
Und hier ist Florian mit Jurassic Park. Langweilige, schniefende Federtiere laufen herum. Leute, habt ihr meine Eier gefressen? Eigentlich müsste man so eine Spaceballs-mässige Parodie dazu machen. Und zwar wäre die Idee, dass dann auch Professor Grant und Professor, weiss ich nicht, Kettler, weiss ich nicht mehr, fanden dann dahin. Zweifel, Kifel, Kettler, ja. Kessler. Und es gibt diesen Kramer-Character und den Grant-Character, also Laura Dern. Und dann kommt quasi Dr. Grant oder ist er, ist Dr. Grant die Frau. Wie auch immer, das ist lange her. Und dann fahren die in diesem Jeep durch die, durch die Jurassic Park. Und dann gibt es ja diese Szene, wo der Bachiosaurus kommt und der Mann sagt zu Laura Dern, schau und dreht sie um. Und ich finde, und dann ist sie, und dann kommt die tolle Musik. Und jetzt müsste Druckluftmusik kommen dann aber. Und ihr fällt so alles aus dem Gesicht und es ist nicht nur diese freudige Erregtheit, sondern dieses What the fuck und es ist einfach so ein riesiges, verschnupftes, grauhaariges Federungetum, das gerade von einem Urzeitkrokodil gefressen wird und sich nicht verteidigt, sondern nur sich nicht verteidigt, hat einen riesigen Keulenschwanz, macht damit nichts. Ja, mit Jagdgebrüll.
Hääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääää Sich nicht verteidigt, hat einen riesigen Keulenschwanz, macht damit nichts. Ja, mit Jagdgebrüll. Und also nervig einfach eine Riesenente läuft herum, fällt hin, rappelt sich auf, fällt noch mal hin, rappelt sich nicht mehr auf, weil es gibt auf, keine Lust mehr aufs Leben und so und es passiert auch nichts. Dann trotzdem, natürlich trotzdem kommt dann Jeff Goldblum an und sagt, find the way und dann fahren die auch mit den Trucks umher, es kommt auch zu dem, nee, in dem Film ist ja alles ein bisschen anders, alles läuft reibungslos, die bleiben dann nicht stehen vom Tyrannosaurus Rex-Gehege. Die sind auch keine Bedrohung. Oh, der T-Rex ist ausgebrochen. Ja. So ein Riesenente, also könnte mich platt treten. Der ist beim HNO-Arzt, das wissen wir doch. Ja, aber eigentlich müsste das doch anhalten, ne, vom T-Rex-Gehege. Und dann kommt da diese Ziege, wird auch reingelassen, der passiert auch gar nichts, weil der T-Rex streichelt sie und schnupft die vielleicht so ein bisschen süss an. Oder sowas, anak quak, kündigt er sich dann an. Das Wasserglas macht dann auch so ekonografisch die Wellen und so. Und dann fahren sie entspannt vor ihm davon. Ich glaube, es ist langsam an der Zeit, dass wir die Dinosaurier langsam von einer wissenschaftlichen Gewissheit in den Raum der Mythologie übertragen. Das war bei vielen Tieren der Fall. dachte man die existieren wirklich bis man gesagt hat nee das ist eher so ein fantasy ding bigfoot yeti
oder so drachen ich glaube drachen ich glaube dinosaurier gehören langsam einfach in den
bereich der der mythologie und wir ignorieren einfach was die diese verdammte paläontologie
zutage fördert und sagen einfach dinosaurier sind jetzt wie drachen und einhörner einfach
fabelwesen fantas Fantasiewesen.
Wie können sie trotzdem noch so cool zeigen?
Wohl eher Blaleontologie.
Ne?
Habe ich recht? Habe ich recht? Ja, du hast schon recht.
Aber du formulierst es
manchmal so spitz, dass ich da gar nicht
mitkomme. Wohl eher Blaleontologie.
Wer? Nee, im Ernst.
Oder Palämonologie.
Ja, okay.
Ich sagte erst, du sagst Paläontologie, aber dann hast du das dann noch abgeändert. Nee, nee. Nee, also das ist, glaube ich, der richtige Schritt. Weil ich habe tatsächlich mal so ein Buch gelesen von so einem Mönch, der so ein bisschen ausgerastet ist, der so ein bisschen gerantet hat, so ein Mönch. Und er hat gesagt, hört auf mit eurem Quatsch, die Leute konzentrieren sich zu sehr auf Fabelwesen. Ja, also das war sein Problem von diesem Mönch, der hat gesagt, die beten zu wenig, sondern Fabelwesen. Und selbst in seinem Kloster wurde schon eines dieser Fabelwesen jetzt an die Wand gemalt, ein Löwe. Und er hat gesagt, Leute, wer glaubt denn, dass es sowas gibt? Also sorry, dieser ganze Kinderquatsch, den ihr euch hier ausdenkt, versucht mal lieber eure Aufmerksamkeit auf die echte Welt zu richten und nicht diese Fabelwesen anzubeten, wo man sich wirklich dachte, ja, es gab wahrscheinlich eine lange Zeit in der Geschichte, wo Löwe und Drache völlig gleichberechtigt nebeneinander standen und man dachte, entweder sind beide echt oder beide Fabelwesen, aber wo man einfach in seinem Leben nie einen Löwen gesehen hat und dieser Mönch auch wirklich, also einer der weirdesten Hot Takes der Geschichte, gesagt hat, verschwendet nicht eure Zeit mit Fabelwesen Löwe, sondern konzentriert euch auf die echten Tiere. Betet lieber an Gott, zu Gott. Ja, betet lieber einen brennenden Busch an, sowas. Aber er hat jetzt schon, was war es für ein spiritueller Lieder? Es war kein Lieder, es war ein klassischer Mönch, katholisch, Mittelalter, hier all in, einfach hatte kein... Aber schon ein bisschen hört auf, über Drachen zu reden und gebetet zu Gott. Ja, im Grunde schon. Und einer der, glaube ich, traurigsten Takes der Geschichte, also die Geschichte strafte ihn Lügen, und mittlerweile hat sich die katholische Kirche von dissenziert. Sag mal wieso. Ja, weil es Löwen wirklich gibt. Naja. Gut, die tragen Sandalen und Crocs ab und zu, da müssen wir nicht drüber reden. Die haben so eine große Thomas-Gotschalk-artige Haare-Frisur. Ja, Locken. Und ehrlich gesagt, habe ich jetzt noch keinen Löwen gesehen. Ausser hinter diesen LED-Screens, die im Zoo aufgestellt werden, die uns suggerieren sollen, dass dahinter echte Tiere sind. Ich habe jetzt noch nie einen Löwen face to face gesehen. Du willst gerade in die Tradition von Konstantinus steigen und sagen, es gibt keine Löwen. Hört auf, euch den Kopf mit diesen billigen Farbewesen vollzustopfen. Okay, alles klar. Ich trete in die Fußstafel von Ridiculous Imagination Nii und sage jetzt mal, gibt's nicht. Weil ich glaube, was hindert denn Zoos daran, dass wir auch übrigens, wenn ich ein Zoo hätte und dann würden die mir sagen, wir haben kein Geld mehr für neue Tiere, kosten viel Geld, wie teuer ist so ein Löwe? Wie teuer ist so ein Löwe? 50 Euro, 50.000 Euro, so was. Kleinwagen und Sportwagen, ja, ne, warum nicht einfach einen grossen LED, so ein Samsung kaufen und dann so hinstellen und dann filmt mal jemand im Vancouver Zoo oder so mal Echtlöwen ab und dann läuft da die ganze Zeit so eine Riesenprojektion. Ja. Und da zeigt man mal die Leute, die das erkennen. Ne, ist eigentlich keine schlechte Idee. Ich glaube eh, dass Hologrammtechnik die meisten Zoos ersetzen wird und dann hast du da so einen Hologrammlöwen, ist auch nicht schlecht. Aber es ist eigentlich keine schlechte Idee, so ein wirklich so ein Zoo, der fast nichts hat. Der hat halt Katzen, Hunde und so eine Ente haben sie eingefangen und mehr und nicht und alle anderen mussten sie verkaufen. Und es war so ein Stück besser als normale Welt. Also ja, Hunde und Katzen, okay, die Ente, nett, es ist wirklich fast sogar schlechter als ein Waldspaziergang. Also es ist wirklich unter der Realität einfach. So will ich der erbärmlichste Zoo der Welt. Ja. Oder du einfach sagst, ab wann macht man Zoo? Ab wann sagt man, wir haben nichts quasi. Aber macht man Zoo? Oh, schön. Ja, gute Frage. Ich finde auch konsequent, dann zu sagen, wir haben nur lame Tiere. Weil echte Zoos ist ein bisschen, ich finde es immer gemein den Tieren gegenüber, weil du hast natürlich lame Tiere, du hast natürlich kack, kack langweilige Tiere, du hast einen Teich, wo auch Enten rumschwimmen, was in allen anderen Orten Kölns schön ist, aber nicht im Zoo, wo daneben auch Flamingos stehen. Ich gucke liebe Flamingos an als diese Basic-Ass-Ente, die wir eh kennen. Und dann gibt es ja auch noch den Streichelzoo im Zoo, der natürlich dann dieses Feature hat, dass man die auch anfassen kann. Das ist wahrscheinlich so der letzte Schritt, wenn du sagst, unsere Tiere sind so lame, dass sie eigentlich auch nicht mehr gefährlich sind, dann geht man über ins Streichelzoo und sagt, ja dann streichel die Ente. Probier es doch mal. Es ist immer eine Frage des Kontextes, ne? Unsere liebe Freundin Jenny Nicholson hat ja auch mal gesagt, es gibt ja die lameste Attraktion im Disneyland, ist der Streichelzoo im Disneyland. Es gibt einen Streichelzoo im Disneyland, wo man Ziegen streicheln kann. Nicht irgendwie Mäuse, Mickey Mouse oder so, sondern halt einfach ... Es ist lächerlich, aber es ist lächerlich, weil es im Disneyland ist. Es ist ja nicht per se lächerlich. Es ist ja an allen anderen Orten eine coole Attraktion. Aber nicht neben fucking Star Wars Ride. Gut, das war auch extrem lame. Ich habe mir davon erzählt, dass in Disneyland haben die Space ... Da wurde der Kopf fast abgerissen. Genau, da auch andere Freizeit war. So lame klingt das aber gar nicht, um ganz ehrlich zu sagen. Eine andere Incident. Das war im R-Park, aber im Disneyland ist das dann, haben die Hyperspace Mountain jetzt aus Space Mountain gemacht. Einfach Hyper draufgeschrieben und dann so ein paar Flaggen hingehangen von Star Wars und dann gesagt, du hast jetzt der neue Ride. Und es ist nichts verändert quasi, das fand ich so faul. Da fand ich dann wiederum auch so ein Hyperspace- Streichelzoo, finde ich auch besser. Du sagst dann einfach so, ja, du darfst jetzt Jedis streicheln. Ja, man zieht so Ziegen-80-Kostüme an. Ja. Und dann kann man die Anfragen. Im Grunde ist Streicheln einfach die letzte Chance, die du hast, wo du einfach sagst, uns fällt nichts mehr ein, die Leute dürfen streicheln. Warum nicht? Streichelst du gerne? Bist du ein Kraul? Ich bin Krauler, ich bin Schmuser, ich bin Kuschler. Ja? So richtig, aber bist du dann auch manchmal, bist du eher der aktive Part oder bist du der, an den sich angeschmiegt wird? Nee, durch meine Größe alleine schon bin ich der, an den angeschmiegt wird. Kommt kaum drum rum. Weil ich kann mich nicht anschmiegen. Wenn ich, ich würde über Leute fallen, wenn ich mich anschmiege. An mich wird sich angeschmiegt, aber ich bin schon ein kuscheliger Kerl. Okay. Nahbarer, kuscheliger Kerl. Finde ich gut. So, ich, wo ihr uns beiden streicheln könnt, wo der Pottersufo streichelt so ist. Ich wollte nämlich kurz noch mal sagen, wir haben nämlich ja eine Tour, die ansteht, die jetzt und die Chancen stehen supergut, genauso
jetzt klappen wird, wie wir das jetzt vortragen.
Wir alle haben Hoffnung verlernt, aber
vielleicht ist jetzt der Zeitpunkt gekommen,
wo man sich ein bisschen wieder aus dem Schrank holen kann, den man
lange verstaut hat.
Ein bisschen Hoffnung ist angebracht, denn es kann gut sein,
dass die nächsten Shows stattfinden.
Stefan hat die Fakten. Genau, das kann
sehr gut sein, weil uns erreichen auch viele Fragen, sind diese Tickets noch gültig? Faustregel, Tickets behalten ihre Gültigkeit. Tickets behalten ihre Gültigkeit. Ein Fan hat vorgeschlagen, dass das der Titel der Tour ist. Ich finde es eigentlich super. Die Tickets behalten ihre Gültigkeit, Tour 2022. Genau, so heißt die ab jetzt. 2019. Also, die grosse Tickets behalten ihre Gültigkeit, Tour 1998 geht jetzt endlich los. Und Faustregel ist, wenn ihr Tickets für ein Konzert hattet, was noch nicht stattgefunden hat. Konzert? Naja, ich will die Faustregel breiter machen, nicht nur für uns, sondern für alle. Erwartet jetzt kein Konzert. Nein. Wir werden keine Instrumente spielen. Okay, ich formuliere es doch einfacher. Wenn ihr noch Tickets für eine Show von uns habt, für eine Wir-Reden-Show noch von uns habt, die nicht stattgefunden hat, dann sind die Tickets noch gültig. Vielleicht eine kleine Beatbox-Einlage, aber ansonsten musikalisch eher unbeeindruckend. Okay, also, aber wenn ihr Tickets habt, deren Abend noch nicht stattgefunden hat, dann sind die noch gültig. Woher wisst ihr, dass der Abend noch nicht stattgefunden hat? Ja, das ist jetzt auch so ein bisschen so eine gefühlige Sache. Am Ende ist es alles eigentlich auch eher eine gefühlige Sache, das ist richtig. Also, wenn ihr jetzt nicht so bescheuert gewesen seid Schaut auf unsere Social-Media-Plattformen, da sind jetzt alle Termine aufgelistet, Stefan liest sie auch nochmal vor. Genau. Und da könnt ihr euch immer einen Überblick überschaffen. Am 5.4. sind wir in Hamburg, am 26.4. in Köln. Der ist kurzfristig verlegt worden, da ist nicht so viel Platz. Er wurde nur so ein Steinwurf weitergeworfen. Also aufwachen, liebe Kölner. 14.5. in Berlin. Am 16.5. auch in Berlin. Hier habt ihr eine E-Mail bekommen, zu welchem Datum ihr da sein könnt. Ja, wir haben euch aufgeteilt, die attraktiven Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen und die nicht so attraktiven, weil eine wollen wir vielleicht ein paar. Und die lauten Lacher, dass nicht alle lauten Lacher in einer Show sind, die haben wir gleichmäßig aufgeteilt. Das Ding ist nämlich, da braucht die Universität der Künste den Saal, wo wir vorher drin waren, wegen der Covid-Situation und deswegen sind wir bereits umgezogen. Am 22.05. sind wir jetzt in Mainz, am 17.06. in Wien, am 5.07. in Hannover, am 30.08. in Leipzig, am 27.9. in Bochum und am 11.10. in München. So, und wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du deinen Hut frisst und das alles umsonst war und wir wieder Korrekturen und Korrekturen der Korrekturen machen müssen? Hut fressen glaube ich nicht, aber so aus Versehen so Rattengift. Okay. Bei uns stand am Haus jetzt ganz viel Rattengift. Ja, Vorsicht. Und das Problem war bei mir quasi, im Eingangsbereich war plötzlich so ein grosser, so ein Edelstahlrohr. Und da stand aber jetzt kein Sticker drauf, was es ist. Und dann habe ich das hochgenommen, weil ich wusste nicht, was es ist, und habe es hochgenommen, reingeguckt, dann war da so, war da was drin und ich habe es geschüttelt und mir angeguckt und genau viel zu nah und viel zu eingehend betrachtet, um dann ein paar Tage später herauszufinden. Da bin ich nämlich an unserem Haus herumgelaufen und dann habe ich auch wieder so ein Ding gesehen und da stand ein großer roter Sticker drauf, wo drauf stand, auf gar keinen Fall anfassen, Rattengift. Ja, ich liebe diese Zettel, dieses Achtung, Ratten, Achtung, Rattengift, wo ich mir denke, wen versucht ihr hier zu schützen? So gibt es Leute, die dann selber in diese Röhre greifen und dann selber in die Falle geraten. Und dann musst du peinlicherweise zum Hausmeister gehen und sagen, ja, ich bin keine Ratte. Ja, das sagen sie alle. Das ist genau das, was eine Ratte sagen würde. Zeigen sie mal, dass sie keine Ratte sind. Zeigen sie mal einen Ausweis. Dann holst du so einen Rattenausweis heraus. Und dann einfach auch so, normalerweise esse ich ja alle roten Krümelchen, die auf dem Boden rumliegen, nur jetzt, wo ich weiß, dass gerade Ratten gejagt werden, mache ich das natürlich nicht, weil kein Rattengift ist. Also wenn ich erst diesen Zettel gesehen hätte, hätte ich hätte ich mich auch kaputt gedacht, welche Trottel würden das denn hochnehmen, dieses Ding, und anfassen oder noch schlimmer sich in den Mund stopfen. Aber jetzt so in der Reihenfolge, in der ich das erlebt habe, wollte ich schon einfach wissen, was dieses Metallding ist, was vor meiner Wohnung liegt. Ich kriege manchmal auch einen Strafzettel und da steht dann drin, ja, sie haben da und da falsch geparkt. Ich denke mir, ich bin seit Jahren doch kein Auto mehr gefahren. Bin das ich? Und dann denke ich mir, gibt es Leute, die gefakte Strafzettel verteilen? Weil du kannst ja einfach statt Köln und dann deine eigene E-Bahn reinschreiben und du sagst, geparkt in irgendeiner Strasse in der Nähe, selbst wenn nur 10% der Leute das bezahlen ...
Also ich will jetzt nicht betrügern, also ...
Nein, ich will jetzt eine Textaufgabe,
keine Handreichung ...
Du druckst einfach tausend Briefe von der Stadt Köln.
Tausend Briefe, okay.
So, und dann sagst du immer hier 25 Euro,
gibst aber als Adresse deine eigene Iban-Nummer an.
Super.
Und dann schmeißt du das überall in die Briefkasten, in ganz Köln und 10% überweisen, 100 Leute, 100 mal 25 Euro, Cash. Und jetzt aber bei der Mathematik-Textaufgabe nicht vergessen, dass hier noch Porto und die Kosten, die entstanden sind, wo Arbeitszeit... Ja, aber wenn das nicht in der Textaufgabe steht, dann muss ich jetzt nicht selber nachfragen, was kostet Porto. Doch. Nee, kein Porto, ich schmeiß das selber ein. Was schick das doch nicht? Du läufst dann rum. Ich lauf rum. Dann musst du abziehen, das Post-Outfit. Da habe ich eine, was hole ich mir da, eine Beefy, eine Capri-Sonne, das sind was, das sind das 2,80 Euro. Genau, und die Sachen, die du nehmen, aber kannst du absetzen. Kann ich alles absetzen? Ich glaube, das ist kein schlechter Betrug, also nicht, dass ihr, aber falls ihr einen sucht. Also falls ihr für einen Roman oder so was oder für eine Breaking Bad-Folge oder so, dann der Held braucht schnell Geld. Held braucht Geld, vielleicht ist das der Titel des Films. Und dann sagt man, ja, ich versuche meine alte, meine Familie zu retten. Oder irgendwie halt so was Sympathisches. So ein Save the Cat-Moment-Moment, wo jemand irgendwie... So ein Lame-is-Breaking-Bad. Ja, genau. Aber statt Crystal Meth macht er so Briefbetrug. Enkelbetrug. So Enkeltricks. Ja, dann lass den so an so einem Fussballplatz vorbeilaufen und dann fliegt der Fussball über den Käfig drüber. Und er klaut den. Nee, und er schießt den zurück. Und jeder... Du brauchst so einen Save-the-Cat-Moment, wo man einfach sagt, ah, der ist nett. Save the ball. Und dann, egal was danach passiert, kann er auch irgendwie in den Drogenkrieg geraten. Du denkst immer, ja, aber der hat ja den Kindern den Ball wieder zurückgegeben. Also so leicht ist es ja. So leicht ist es ja. Achtet mal drauf, wenn ihr eine Serie schaut. Meistens gibt es bei den Figuren am Anfang, die irgendwas Nettes, damit man sich denkt, ja, den finde ich gut, den finde ich sympathisch. Ja, das ist der bekanntesten Tipps wahrscheinlich für Drehbuchschreiben. Ja, dass man eine Katze aus dem Baum rettet. Man muss die Katze am Anfang retten, der Protagonist, man muss mit dem mitfühlen, er muss was Nettes tun. Und manchmal ist es literally eine Katze. Ja. Oder jemandem fällt irgendwie ein Snickers aus der Tasche und er hebt es auf und gibt es dem einfach so völlig, passt null zur Story völlig willkürlich irgendwie in so einem Horrordrama oder so, aber du brauchst einfach diese kleinen Momente.
Ja, achtet mal auf diese merkwürdigen Momente. Bei Star Wars, da ist ja das Snickers-Moment drin, der ja gar nicht in die Story passt.
Aber wo Skywalk am Anfang bei Obi-Wan die ganze Zeit, da gibt es ja dann diese Zehn-Minuten-Sequenz, wo er hinter Obi-Wan herlackelt durch Tatooine.
Genau.
Und man sieht dann diesen Close-Up. Aber wo Luke Skywalker am Anfang bei Obi-Wan, wo die ganze Zeit, da gibt es ja dann diese Zehn-Minuten-Sequenz, wo er hinter Obi-Wan herlackelt durch Tatooine.
Und man sieht dann diesen Close-Up von diesem Snickers, der beim Gehen immer weiter aus der Tasche gedrückt, ehe er irgendwann in den heissen Sand fällt, oh nein, und Luke nimmt den, überlegt kurz den selber zu essen, weil er bei Uncle Owen und Dings, so was nie gesehen hat. Petunia nicht hat, ja. Und es gibt dann zurück an Obi-Wan. Nee, das ist auch wichtig, du brauchst in jeder Situation auch irgendwie General Grievous, als der das erste Mal eingeführt wird auf seinem Raumschiff, dann steht so ein Druide am Kaffeeautomaten und sagt, oh, ich hab leider kein Geld dabei, Roger, Roger, und er sagt so, ach, zahl ich dir. Ach, mach ich so. Und dann nimmt er aus seiner Tasche so eine imperiale
Credit-Münze, he he he he,
zahl ich dir, und
wirft es für den Druiden
in den Kaffeeautomaten und schon denkt man sich,
das ist ein netter Kerl, das ist ein netter Kerl,
der hilft seinen Mitarbeitern,
das ist ein netter Kerl. Ich meine, danach
will er alle unsere Protagonisten
umbringen, aber er ist ein netter Kerl.
Man stellt sich nie die Frage, ist er vielleicht böse? Nee, das ist so, du brauchst, und es ist egal, welche Krolltaten er danach macht, wenn er einmal sowas Gutes macht, kein Problem. Es ist an der Kasse und kauft sich da irgendwie so ein Milky Way oder sowas, kriegt Wechselgeld zurück, guckt nochmal und sagt, Entschuldigung, sie haben mir zu viel Wechselgeld gegeben und gibt nochmal was zurück. Und dann denkst du dir, das ist ein ehrlicher Typ, das ist ein netter Typ. Man denkt sich, das ist ein ehrlicher Typ und so gehen die auch einkaufen. So gehen die auch einkaufen. So gehen die einkaufen. Ich würde gerne mal so eine Show machen im Star Wars Universum oder in, keine Ahnung, einem anderen bekannten Franchise, wo man aber jetzt nicht dann diese ganzen Sachen passieren, diese Abenteuersachen passieren, sondern einfach so, wo man so ein Leben, so Seinfeld-artig, wo man so Slices of Life sich angucken kann. So Wohnungssuche in Coruscant. Wohnungssuche auf Coruscant. Oh, und ein Termin, Besichtigungstermin. Der aber am Südteil des Planeten ist, wo man erst mal 19 Tage hintraveln muss, weil nicht alle haben ja Lightspeed und sowas oder so einen schicken Flitzer, der wird erstmal schön getrappt. Und warum war die Wohnung jetzt so untergesetzt? Naja, hier, wir haben im Fenster ist so ein kreisförmiger Ausschnitt drin. Woher kommt der? Das dürfen wir datenschutzrechtlich nicht sagen. Aber nur so viel, hier gab es mal einen Vorfall. Wirklich? Aber das ist jetzt der sechshundertste Stock, wenn ich da jetzt so ein Loch im Fenster habe, ist das nicht schlecht? Naja, Sie können ja versuchen, ob Sie nicht so Glaser-Druiden bekommen. Aber die haben auch gerade nicht so viel Zeit, da müssen Sie sich jetzt frühzeitig einen Termin suchen. Die Glaser-Druiden sind bis auf die nächsten drei Jahre ausgebucht. Haben Sie da einen Kontakt für mich? Ja, schreiben Sie sich. Haben Sie einen Stift? Sekunde. Ich kann es Ihnen hier sonst kurz. Hier ist dieses kleine Hologramm. Achtung, ich spiele es kurz ab. Glasadroiden! Wir sind Glasadroiden! Wir reparieren, wir tauschen aus Glasadroiden auf Coruscant im Sektor BBBBB 29,3. Ja, die klingen gut. Die sind super, die machen einen guten Job. Aber wie gesagt, ein bisschen ausgebucht. Naja, ähm, gut. Dann, ähm, also wenn Sie jetzt... Und welcher Vorfall, also weil Sie sagen Vorfall, in welchem Vorfall ist ein kreisförmiger Ausschnitt in einem Glasfenster? Ich darf es ja eigentlich nicht sagen, aber hier war mal kurz das Gemach von Prinzessin Lea. Von Prinzessin Lea? Ja, kennen Sie? Ja, natürlich kenne ich die. Ich habe das ganz intensiv verfolgt. Die ist ja gestorben, weil sie Kinder zur Welt gebracht hat. Das hat niemand verstanden, warum gestorben ist. Das habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Auf jeden Fall, hier gab es wohl mal einen Kopfgeldattentat. Einen Kopfgeldattentat? Einen Versuch, einen Versuch. Und dann sind hier diese kleinen Giftraupen reingekrochen. Moment mal, hier hat jemand versucht, mit Giftraupen Prinzessin Leia zu töten? Genau, aber ein Jedi war zur Stelle. Ein waschlechter Jedi. Zum Glück. Und wir sehen, währenddessen sehen wir das Gespräch von spannenden Dingen, die mal passiert sind.
Weirden, aber spannenden Dingen.
Passiert überhaupt mal was? Wenigstens passiert was in der Story, die sie sich erzählen.
Ich finde das super. Aber es geht eigentlich nur um sehr langweilige Sachen.
Und dann der gleiche Charakter ist dann am gleichen Tag nochmal in deren Space-Rewe.
Hyper-Space-Rewe.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Und dann auch so ein riesiger Hutte vor dir an der Kasse,
eine riesige Schleimspur hinterlässt.
Und der macht dann nicht so einen Save-the-Cat-Moment.
Der klaut nämlich dann die letzte Beefy aus dem Regal.
Ja, der macht so einen Save-so-Kill-the-Cat-Moment.
Kill-the-Cat, wo du einfach schon so direkt merkst, oh, der ist böse.
Oh, der ist böse, glaube ich.
Vor allem, also hat der dann Personal, der hinter ihm immer die Schleimspur aufwischt, oder ist dem das egal? Das ist wie so Reverse Curling. Okay. Du hast so zwei Curling-Typen, die hinter ihm alles wegwiesen. Die, die die Spuren verwischen. Und hinter denen sind wiederum Leute die deren Spuren. Das sind auch Roten. Auch Roten. Und alle, die an dem stehen, würden denken, ich wüsste, wie ihr das verbessern könnt, euer System.
Aber sie kriegen es nicht hin. Oh, nervig, oder diese Schleimspur. Super nervig, würde mich auch nerven. Du hast mir erzählt, im Vertrauen, dass du nicht so gut geschlafen hast. Aber du hast mir auch erzählt, dass du eine spannende Traumreise vollzogen hast. Ich weiss nicht, was los ist, aber ich habe irgendwie bin ich, als ich ins Bett gestiegen bin, habe ich irgendwie angefangen eine grossartige Traumreise vollzogen ist. Ich weiß nicht, was los ist, aber ich habe irgendwie bin ich, als ich
ins Bett gestiegen bin, habe ich
irgendwie angefangen, eine grossartige Traumreise
zu starten. Und zwar dachte ich, in einem Flugzeug...
Aber erst mal meine Frage, kommt das häufiger vor?
Ja, tatsächlich, weil es ist ja
so ein bisschen das Problem, wenn du mal nicht schlafen kannst.
Also letzte Woche konnte ich
schon in derselben Nacht nicht schlafen,
Sonntag auf Montag, konnte ich überhaupt nicht schlafen.
Sonntag auf Montag kann niemand
schlafen. Es ist irgendwie furchtbar. Und ich bin
auch irgendwie super spät ins Bett gegangen, bin ich um drei Uhr
Und schon in derselben Nacht nicht schlafen, Sonntag auf Montag. Konnte ich überhaupt nicht schlafen. Sonntag auf Montag kann niemand schlafen. Es ist irgendwie furchtbar. Und ich bin auch irgendwie super spät ins Bett gegangen, bin ich um drei Uhr ins Bett gegangen, dann konnte ich drei Stunden nicht schlafen, dann war sechs Uhr morgens und dann dachte ich, jetzt stehe ich auf. Und dann bist du halt den ganzen Tag kaputt. Das ist so, du hast einen kompletten Tag, der wertlos ist. Das ist das schlimmste Gefühl, weil du kannst nichts machen, auch irgendwie kannst du keinen Film gucken oder so, weil du bist halt super müde. Und das ist einfach so ein verschwendeter Tag. Und du musst den aber trotzdem noch durchleben. Das ist furchtbar. Und jetzt dachte ich mir, jetzt aber nächste Woche nicht wieder, aber nicht wieder. Und dann dachte ich mir, als ich im Bett lag, Sonntagnacht, dachte ich mir, nee, ich mache eine Traumreise, um besser einschlafen zu können. Hast du die, hast du die gebucht, hast du die im Reisebüro gebucht? Da habe ich mir schön was rausgesucht und dann dachte ich mir so eine schöne Traumreise und dann dachte ich sofort an. All in, all in Reise? All inclusive, alles mit dabei. Und dann dachte ich mir natürlich, was machst du schön zur Entspannung Flugzeugabsturz. Und dann dachte ich mir. Aber jetzt mal unter uns, ne? Jetzt mal all bullshit und jokes aside. Hast du das geplant oder ist es passiert? Wie geplant? Hast du die Traumreise wirklich so geplant? Hast du dich am Schreibtisch gesetzt und gedacht, ich will jetzt... Nein, nein, ich habe es nicht geplant. Ich dachte mir, ich fange bei einem Flugzeug am Sturz an, das ist ja immer spannend, und mal schauen, was passiert. Und dann dachte ich, es hilft, aber tatsächlich war das so aufregend. Nervenaufreiben. Nervenaufreiben. Denkt man gar nicht. Weil ich dachte so, was mache ich jetzt, wenn das Flugzeug wirklich abstürzt über dem Meer, kann man da noch rausspringen? So, und dann dachte ich so, alle schreien und haben sich abgefunden damit, aber ich bin der Einzige, der die Tür aufreißt und versucht rauszuspringen. Was ich immer denke, und in gewisser Weise wurde ich da jetzt auch bestätigt, als Kind dachte ich mir, angenommen, weil ich dachte, mein Vater ist mal von der Leiter gefallen und es hat ihm wehgetan. Und ich dachte, ha, Trottel, weil, wenn man sich das vorstellt, wie der Leiter umkippt langsam, wenn man im letzten, wenn man im richtigen Moment, wenn man im richtigen Moment abspringt, landet man ja sanft. Wann willst du abspringen? Wenn die Leiter nach hinten umfällt. Nee, dann nicht. Nach vorne umfällt, okay. Und du willst von der Leiter abspringen? Ja. Aber im richtigen Moment, wenn man abspringt, im richtigen Moment, dass man quasi so eine Aufwärtsbewegung hat, dann muss man die Leiter von sich unten wegschossen. Ja, Stefan, danke, dass du mich im Krankenhaus besuchst, das ist ein netter, konstruktiver Beitrag. Ich habe jetzt beide
Beine gebrochen, aber
danke für die Erklärung. Und dann
ist mir aufgefallen, weil
es gibt diese eine Sportart,
dieses Free-Skiing-
Gedöns, habe ich gesehen bei den Olympischen
Spielen, wo die
eine Rampe runterfahren und dann
sehr hoch in die Luft springen, so 20 Meter
und so. Und ich dachte mir, während
ich geguckt habe, wie landen die denn jetzt?
Wo darin landen die? Und die
Antwort ist, einfach eine Rampe.
Also deren
Skispringen landet so, genau, ist wie beim Skispringen
einfach, die landen halt nicht auf dem flachen
Boden, sondern die haben halt
eine Rampe. Und jetzt dachte
ich mir, wie geil, warum landen wir nicht wenn wir wir auf dem Mond landen, bauen wir so aufwendige Stopp-Systeme und Fallschirme, wir müssen doch einfach nur im richtigen Winkel auf so einen Krater kommen und dann, der muss dann schön gross sein und dann langsam abflachen. Und dann aber auf der anderen Seite wieder hoch und dann 360 oder so. Und dann, ja geht.. Ich denke mir, weil das löst doch alle Probleme. Wir als Menschen könnten ja quasi, wir müssen ja nicht bremsen oder so, wir müssen ja nur im richtigen Winkel abgebremst werden. Weil diese Skispringerinnen teilweise sind ganz, ganz tief gefallen, aber dann, weil die halt im richtigen Winkel dann aufkommen und das eine sehr lange Auslaufzone ist, total geil, landen die einfach am Ende, stehen sie, als wären sie nicht gerade 20 Meter in die Tiefe gefallen. Das heißt, du würdest sagen, das Mondraumschiff sollte so Ski ausfahren, um dann im letzten Moment in den Krater einzutauchen und da wie so ein Skischpringer abzuholen. Wenn der Krater groß genug ist und du im richtigen Winkel drauf landest und der langsam deine quasi Reibung entsteht und dann landet man langsam unten. Ja, völlig klasse. Super. Und das wäre für deinen Traum ja auch spannend gewesen, wenn du in einem richtigen Moment abgesprungen wärst. Ja, ich dachte dann so, weil dann habe ich so ein bisschen gedacht, okay, stirbt man dann, wenn man da durch die Tür geht, weil der Fahrtwind so krass ist oder so? Dachte ich, nee, ich kann nicht jetzt schon sterben. Das wäre keine wirklich interessante Geschichte, die nach drei Minuten sofort endet. Dann dachte ich mir, dann pack ich mir noch so Rettungsequipment. Ich pack mir noch so Rettungsequipment. Achso, ich dachte, du rettest eine Katze am Anfang. Das ist der mit dir selber. Ich reisse eine Katze von dem Schoss einer Passagierin, steck sie mir in den Pullover. Das ist Diebstahl. Nee, Katzen gehören allen. Pack mir Rettungsequipment, spring raus und dann habe ich gehört, weil das Problem ist, wenn du auf Wasser aufschlägst, dann kriegt dich die Wasseroberflächenspannung. Und wobei ich gar nicht so weiss, wie das im Meer ist, wenn da so Wellen sind und so. Kannst du abhusten? Bitte huste ab. Also ich weiss gar nicht, wie das ist, wenn das im Meer ist oder so mit Wellen, ob da auch eine Oberflächenspannung ist. Das wäre besser, wenn es höher weitergesprochen hätte. Nee, was kann ich hier? Hey, da ist die Oberflächenspannung. Nee, hustet die wieder ab. Weiß ich gar nicht. Hier hast du seit 30 Jahren nicht abgehustet. Das darfst du jemandem nie sagen, das ändert sich die Stimme für immer.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie das ist, wenn da so Wellen sind
mit der Oberflächenspannung. Auf jeden Fall habe ich bei
Mythbusters gehört, du musst irgendwas unter dich werfen,
wenn du also ganz schnell runterstürzt auf Wasser,
musst du irgendwas unter dich werfen,
dass unter dir die Wasseroberfläche gebrochen wird.
Weil man ja so beweglich ist und nicht in Todesangst
in der Stache ist.
Ich dachte, ich fliege da so ein paar Minuten lang und dann war ich im Wasser, dann hatte ich so ein paar Koffer, im Grunde war es Castaway und dann dachte ich mir, hatte ich so ein Schwimm-U-Boot alleine und so ein aufblasbares Ding. Und meine Koffer hattest du auch? Deine Koffer? Nee, meine Koffer hatte ich nicht, nur einen Koffer und dann dachte ich, ich bin dann ganz nass und dann habe ich überlegt, wie ich das machen würde, hänge ich meine nasse Kleidung außen an dieses Schlauchboot dran, damit es trocknet und so und nachts, wie würde ich das dann machen, um zu überleben? Und ich habe mir dann überlegt, was ich mache und dann dachte ich mir, was ist da so drin in so einem Rettungsboot, sind da vielleicht Spielkarten drin und dann kann ich die auswendig lernen. Ich würde die dann in Deck Karten nehmen und mischen und dann die Reihenfolge der Karten auswendig lernen und wenn ich das kann, nochmal neu mischen, weil du musst dich ja irgendwie aktiv halten, mental, und dann dachte ich mir, kann ich das machen, oder ich dachte, ich schreibe alle Songtexte auf, die ich kenne, an die ich mich erinnere. Ja, mir würde keiner einfallen, ganz ehrlich. Ich dachte auch, weil gestern lief auch plötzlich abends wieder der Film Yesterday, der Film, wo die Beatles plötzlich nicht mehr existieren. Genau, und der eine will Yesterday nachkomponieren. Nee, und der eine ist halt ein Gitarrist, Musiker und hat halt noch alle Songs drauf und wird dann sozusagen alle Beatles in Personalunion und wird sehr berühmt. Und die Beatles verschwinden einfach? Die Beatles, er hat einen Unfall oder sowas und dann plötzlich ist er in einem Universum, wo es die Beatles einfach nie gab. Und er trifft dann aber irgendwann auch John Lennon. Kein guter Film, aber er hat lustige Momente, die mich so immer in Bracht. Und er kann sich aber an alle Songs erinnern und komponiert ihn danach und so. Und ich dachte mir, selbst wenn ich in so einem fantastischen, tollen Paralleluniversum lande, keine Chance, dass ich, selbst wenn es Stanley Kubrick nicht gäbe oder so. Ja, drehe mal 2001 nach. Ich könnte in keine Lücke irgendeines anderen Menschen reinarbeiten. Könntest du, angenommen die Beatles würden verschwinden, was könntest du daraus ziehen?
We are all in the yellow submarine, yellow submarine, yellow submarine. Und dann würdest du quasi erstmal bei Antenne Köln einen Termin buchen und sagen, ich und meine Ukulele und das nachsingen und er so, ja, mal schauen. Es ist schwierig, es ist wirklich schwierig.
Sollte man vielleicht sogar mal machen als Prank, einfach irgendwo hingehen und einen offensichtlichen Beatles-Song als Eigenkreation vorstellen und zu einem Plattenlabel gehen und mit so einer Ukulele na na na, na na na na ja, ja, schon ganz nett. Aber habe ich schon mal gehört. Aber habe ich schon mal gehört, leider. Ja, ich dachte, ich schreibe alle Songtexte auf, die ich kenne. Und dann war ich natürlich, mittlerweile war es zwei Uhr nachts, und dann versuche ich natürlich genau das zu machen. Ach, du hast in Echtzeit geträumt. Ich habe in Echtzeit geträumt. Das ist das Problem, das ist der Anfängerfehler. Du kannst ja mehr Dinge erleben in kurzer Zeit als im echten Leben, deswegen ist es schön zu träumen. Ja, das stimmt. Ich dachte, das ist ein bisschen Betrug. Und dann dachte ich ja, an wie viele Songtexte kann ich mich erinnern? Today is gonna be the day that you gonna bring it back to ... Und dann halt so, ist halt viel so ... Und dann habe ich echt überlegt, wie viele Songs, und dann habe ich so bei zehn Songs versucht, wie weit ich komme, und dann so. Und das ist ja das Anstrengendste, was es gibt für Skins, sich an Sachen zu erinnern. Also ich war full on Hardcore-Wachmodus in dem Moment. Auch geschwitzt? Auch geschwitzt und dann dachte ich mir, will ich eine Insel finden oder nicht? Weil einerseits... Ach, du warst immer noch in diesem Szenario... Ich war immer noch in einem Schlauchboot. Im Schlauchboot. Und ich dachte mir, will ich eine Insel finden oder nicht? Weil einerseits eine Insel ist natürlich... Fliegen können oder so kam, didn't pass your mind. Nein, nein, nein. Die Frage war, will ich eine Insel finden oder nicht? Weil einerseits eine Insel ist natürlich gut. Fliegen können oder so kam, didn't pass your mind. Nein, nein, nein. Okay. Die Frage war, will ich eine Insel finden? Weil wenn das natürlich jetzt Land ist, wo Leute leben, super, du bist gerettet. Aber wenn da niemand ist, ist es vielleicht auch schlechter, als wenn du auf dem See bist, in deinem orangenen Schlauchboot, wo dich jemand findet. Auf der Insel vielleicht nicht. Aber ich habe mir dann entschieden, dass ich doch gerne eine Insel finden würde. Dann habe ich auch eine Insel gefunden, tatsächlich. Das war ganz praktisch. Aber so Convenience kann dann doch am Puzur rein. Ja, ich habe mir dann überlegt, ein paar Wochen lang war ich dann schon da auf dem Schlauchboot. Und wieder Echtzeit. Wieder Echtzeit alles. Und dann war ich auf der Insel und da gab es dann auch so Krabben und die habe ich angefangen zu jagen mit einer Harpune. Wo hast du die Harpune hergab? Die waren im Koffer. Ich glaube in dem Remover. Die sind in dem Rettungsaufblasboot. Da war drin Wasser, Nahrung, Spielkarten, Signalpistole, Harpune. Und ich glaube, ich wurde von einem Hai angegriffen. Aber da dachte ich mir, ich stelle mich lieber tot. Ach so. Aber cool, dass du diesen Part überspringst. Und dann war auch ein Sturm, aber das ist ja egal. Nee, ich weiß nicht, warum ich mir überbringst du den Part mit dem Hai? Ich dachte mir, weil ich habe dann noch andere so Sachen, so Kisten und so hatte ich dann noch so von dem Wrack, von dem Flugzeugwrack und die habe ich alle so mit Schnüren an mein Boot gebunden, so dass die immer so hinter mir herziehen. Und dann kam aber der Sturm und dann habe ich mich selber festgebunden mit ganz viel Seilen am Boot und an den anderen Gepäckstücken.
Zurück zum Hai, der dich angegriffen hat. Was war das für ein Hai?
Und ja, da wurde ich nur kurz mit der Harpune, aber dann war ich auf der Insel und dann habe ich da so angefangen, diese Krabben zu jagen und Kokosnüsse zu essen und so.
Und dann dachte ich mir, wenn ich ein Schiff sehe, dann mache ich ganz viel Rauch, dann verbrenne ich nasse Palmen, nasse Palmenblätter und Gott sei Dank war an dem Remover-Koffer, der da mit runterfiel, auch so ein großer Kanister, Kanister mit Benzin und ich denke, wie hätte das ein Handgebäck bekommen? Und ich habe dann noch und die Harpune auch, ja, und dann habe ich noch dann tatsächlich so ein altes Schmugglerversteck gefunden auf der Insel, wo so alte Waffen waren. Was du als ein Paar, den du normalerweise überspringen würdest beim Erzählen. Dann habe ich auch überlegt, ob ich gerne so Ureinwohner treffen würde. Dann dachte ich, nee. Dann habe ich auch keine gefunden auf der Insel. Und dann habe ich die so ein bisschen erforscht und dann erst fand ich diese Kokoskrabben total ekelhaft, aber dann habe ich die umgebracht. Ich hatte meine normale Kleidung an, aber da war so dann so diese britische Soldatenuniformen in diesem Schmugglerversteck, weil die Schmuggler, die brauchen natürlich auch so Deckidentitäten und deswegen haben die nicht nur ihre Schmuggelware dort versteckt, sondern auch so Uniformen, damit die, wenn die da ankommen oder so, damit sie dann als Schmuggler irgendwie durchgehen, als Soldaten von der Krone oder was auch immer. Und dann dachte ich mir erst so, wow, das sind ja echt krasse Relikte, die eigentlich in ein Museum gehören, aber schon auch cool. Und dann habe ich mir bei dieser alten... Schon auch noch mein Traum. Ja, dann dachte ich mir, ich muss eigentlich alle anziehen.
Dann hatte ich so ein Säbel an der Seite und dann waren auch so
Gewehre und Waffen, habe ich mir selber beigebracht,
wie man mit denen schießt und dann habe ich mit denen die Krabben
abgeschossen.
Mit Kanonen auf Krabben, ey.
Und dann, ja,
irgendwann glaube ich, war dann so ein...
Dann habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich nicht
auf die Schiffe, die vorbeifahren, schießen soll, damit die auf mich aufmerksam werden. Aber ich glaube, ich habe nicht getroffen. Naja, und dann habe ich überlegt, wie würde dann das aussehen, nachdem ich gerettet wurde. Also dann hast du ja eine Megastory. Aber was machst du damit? Geht. Es kommt noch mal, wie man das erzählt. Also du hättest eine Megastory, wenn du Sachen wie das Schmugglerversteck ein bisschen mehr thematisieren würdest. Oh, und ich glaube, ich hatte noch so einen anderen Typen im Schlauchbude, den ich nicht gern gegessen habe. Aber das ist ja egal. Ja, auch sowas hilft für die Story. Und dann habe ich überlegt, was machst du dann? Gehst du in eine Talkshow? Weil dann kommen ja ganz viele Anfragen, so Zeitungen und so wollen dich interviewen. Und du sagst, so mache ich jetzt ein Buch oder gehe ich jetzt in eine Radiotalkshow, WDR 2, mein grosses Interview, 20 Minuten, ich erzähle alles oder machen wir eine Almost Daily Spezial, wo ich das erzähle, weil dann geht es ja eigentlich erst los. Und dann dachte ich mir, hat man nicht dann Sehnsucht nach dieser Insel wieder irgendwann? Und sagt man dann nicht irgendwie, ich will wieder zurück auf die Insel? Okay, unterm Strich, hast du nicht geschlafen? Ich habe nicht geschlafen die ganze Nacht, ich habe mir das überlegt und habe lange überlegt, wie ich es machen soll und dann dachte ich mir, nee, ich habe so viele Fehler gemacht beim ersten Durchgang. Ich mache es nochmal. Oh Gott, oh Gott. Oder habe ich es nochmal gemacht? Oh mein Gott. Aber die gleichen Fehler wieder gemacht. Und ja, es hat nicht funktioniert, ich bin überhaupt nicht eingeschlafen dadurch. Weil du den Traum ausgewählt hast mit vier von fünf Aufregendsternen. Weißt du, du musst unten rechts gucken, da ist deine grosse Seite stehen in deinem Traumlexikon. Und du hast jetzt quasi dann die einsame Insel, Schiffbruch oder Piloten, Fehler, Absturz, whatever. Und hast unten aber nicht gesehen, dass die sehr aufregend ist. Die war sehr aufregend, ja. Vier aufregend, ja. Nicht empfohlen zum Einschlafen. Null von fünf Erotik, vier von fünf Aufregung und drei von fünf Schmuggel und zwei von fünf Anspruch. Die hast du genommen und fünf von fünf Schmuggel, Daumen hoch, Tipp, unser Schmuggel-Tipp der Woche, Schmuggel-Tipp und die hast du ausgewählt. Ja. Da musst du jetzt auch wissen, was du bekommst. Ich habe mich falsch entschieden. Ich habe mich definitiv falsch entschieden. Und ich überlege dann auch immer so, was ich machen würde. Und ich komme immer wieder darauf zurück, egal in welcher Situation, man ist mit Freunden auf einer Insel, man ist irgendwie, Zivilisation geht unter. Und mein Job ist immer, ich will Wasser kondensieren. Und dann überlege ich immer so, wie ich Wasser kondensiere und dann nehme ich mehr Wasser und dann stelle ich das in die Sonne
und dann kondensiert es und dann ist es
trinkbar und so und das habe ich dann
auch überlegt, wie viel kriegt man da pro Tag,
wie viel Wasser ist dann auf so einem
Schlauchboot drauf und so und
wie viel ist in der Kokosnuss drin.
Cool.
Nee, nee, finde ich
richtig gut.
Ja, aber es ist schwierig, man denkt sich auch so irgendwann, Körper, was ist los, warum schläfst du nicht Ich glaube, es ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein gut. Ja, aber es ist schwierig. Man denkt sich auch so, irgendwann Körper, was ist los, warum schläfst du nicht ein, was kann ich machen?
Und dann greift die Panik, weil du ja weißt, Stefan Tietze will um 8.30 Uhr aufnehmen. Und dann kannst du ja auch nicht sagen, gut.
Mein erster Gedanke wäre, eigentlich, wenn mir jemand sagt, ich kann von Sonntag auf Montag nicht schlafen, wäre, ah, was hast du denn immer montags, was du vielleicht Bock hast und wer dich vielleicht dann nervt, das frage ich aber nur nicht, weil ich deinen Montagstermin mache. Ja, nee, ist es so, ich weiss ja, woran es liegt, es liegt an der Doppelmate. Das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Sonntags ist mein besonderer Tag, da bin ich verrückt,
und da trinke ich zwei Flaschen Mate an einem Tag.
An einem Abend. Und manchmal auch
abends, ja. Und ich bin
selber einfach so dumm,
weil ich mir denke, ja gut, es ist jetzt 19 Uhr,
aber ich gehe ins Bett um was weiß ich, eins oder so,
das ist ja mehr als genug Zeit, aber nee.
Das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Es ist immer dasselbe,
ich bin einfach der dümmste Mensch der Welt.
Dieses ganze Kack vorgeblänkelt.
Ich habe auch schon überlegt, ich lag tatsächlich
schon im Bett und dachte, lohnt es sich
jetzt zu erbrechen?
Dass ich irgendwie
die Mate aus mir rauskriege,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass das was bringt,
weil damit Koffein im Körper ist,
muss es ja schon verdaut sein oder so, keine Ahnung.
Ich dachte mir, was kann ich jetzt machen?
Ich weiß nicht, wie schnell. Ja, wie kriege ich jetzt mein Blut los?
Wie kriege ich jetzt bestenfalls möglichst viel Blut aus mir raus? Wie kann ich mich jetzt möglichst schnell erschöpfen? Es ist total bescheuert. Es ist einfach dumm. Ja, na ja. Ich verstehe schon. Man gönnt sich ja auch sonst nichts. Und dann ist es doch schön, wenn man sich dann mal so eine Mate reinschiebt. Du, weil das war früher war es normal. Zwei Flaschen Mate pro Tag. Du bist ein bisschen älter. Bin ich jetzt zurückgetreten
auf Anraten
von mir selbst, der hatte so geht es nicht weiter.
Von deinem Ärzteteam, von deinem zwölfköpfigen
Ärzteteam. Von deinem Chirurgenteam.
Ich habe jetzt nur noch eine Flasche Mate pro Tag,
nur eben sonntags zwei.
Hier kennen mein Team.
Ja, meine Leute, meine Anwälte.
Meine Anwälte. Mein Team,
mein Berater, Stab, hätten Stab gern. gern. Stell dir vor, du hast einen eigenen Stab. Erklären Sie das mit meinem Stab. Erklären Sie das mit meinem Beraterstab. Ach, das ist schon gut. Ich will aber so ganz verschiedene Leute in meinem Stab. Einmal so den super krassen Bürokraten, dann den Anwalt, dann aber auch irgendwie so ein kleines Kind, so ein Genie-Kind oder so,
irgendwie das so allein im Raum ist oder so Prodigy-mässig, der irgendwie dann so zwölf Jahre alt ist, aber halt so mit kleinen Klötzen spielt, aber damit die ganze Welt versteht. Die ganze Welt versteht irgendwie so. Und dann die Band The Prodigy. Die ist auch da. Für viele Leute. Und dann irgendwie so ein Kräuterkundler, der irgendwie für alles das perfekte Kraut hat.
Irgendwie der immer so irgendwelche Fernöchens. Wie viele Leute. Und dann irgendwie so ein Kräuterkundler, der irgendwie
für alles das perfekte Kraut hat.
Irgendwie der immer so irgendwelche
fernöstlichen spirituellen Kräuterteemischungen
hat für alle Situationen.
Ich würde jetzt gerne alle Klassen, die man bei
WoW oder Guild Wars nehmen kann.
Ich würde gerne Waldläufer, Elementarmagier.
Ja, dann irgend so ein Priester,
irgendwie sowas, der dann segnen kann.
Und ich will mir alle Buffs holen. Aus allen Bereichen will ich mir alles holen.
Das wäre so mein Beraterstab, das wäre mein Board.
Ja, ich finde es nicht schlecht.
Also du brauchst Leute, die logisch denken können, du brauchst Leute, die strategisch, narzisstisch denken können.
Und du brauchst halt einen, der so keine Fragen stellt, einfach sehr so Grobowski, wo du einfach weißt, he's getting things done.
Du brauchst einen, der erst schlägt und dann nachfragt, was hier eigentlich muss. Genau, der so komplett loyal ist, wo du weißt, der erledigt das. Der ist auch im Zweifel bereit, andere Stabsmitglieder auszuschalten. Der ist so dein erster, wo du auch sagst, so das Prodigy-Kind, also der Sohn von dem Prodigy-Sänger, der ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig, der ist so ein bisschen kritisch, der stellt Fragen, die mir nicht gefallen, die ich nicht beantworten kann, wo ich keine Antwort drauf habe, das mag ich nicht, schalt den mal aus.
Stell den mal still.
Das Problem, wir sprechen halt nicht die Sprache, wir sprechen jetzt nicht die Bluffer-Sprache.
Wir sprechen nicht die Gangster-Sprache, überhaupt nicht.
Aber es macht uns vielleicht noch gruseliger.
Ich finde es immer gruseliger, wenn Bösewichte normal sprechen. Wenn die normaler Bösewichte sind und je mehr man auch von sich daran erkennt, desto böser finde ich die. Wenn das Grauen nahbar ist. Weil dann sucht man das auch bei sich. Ich habe gehofft, dass du das nicht sagst. Weil, ich weiß nicht, nichts mehr. Aber immer, Blösewichtige sind immer so überzeichnet. Mit der Katze auf dem Schoss, die gekrault wird und sowas. Und so super reiche Menschen. Mit denen kann man sich nicht identifizieren. Du willst eher so einen Jogginghosen-Jeans-Westen-Typ. Der dann so reinkt, so, hey Leute, alles klar, setzt euch mal, lasst uns mal schnacken so. Was ist los? Ich habe ihre Frau gekidnappt. Genau. Wir können darüber reden. Wollt ihr noch ein Wasser? Entschuldigung, ihr steht hier so ganz trocken da. Wollt ihr nicht echt ein Wasser? Kein Kaffee oder so? Das ist halt geil. Das ist halt dann sofort gruselig. Wollt ihr einen Kaffee oder nicht? Oder einen Tee? Ich habe Hibiskus, Kombucha, grüner Tee. Einfach nichts, ich will nur meine Frau. Haben wir noch was von dem Minz? Wir haben so eine Minz-Lakritz-Mische. Hören Sie, ich will nur meine Frau wieder haben. Was, was, was? Ja, das machen wir schon, aber jetzt trinkt doch erstmal was. Ihr seid ja völlig ausgetrocknet. Will ich nur meine Frau wiedersehen. Wie geht's dir? Also, nee, dann machen wir zwei Mal. Trenn Sie mir zu! Es ist doch gut, entspann dich, entspann dich, ganz locker. Ich habe jetzt, stört die Musik? Ja, ehrlich gesagt, ja. Gut, alles klar, dann mache ich die Musik. Was ist das, The Prodigy? Das ist The Prodigy, ja, das ist echt super, weil die habe ich nämlich gefangen in meinem Keller und lasst die für mich spielen, Superband, Superband. Oh Gott. Und die haben ein komplettes Album geschrieben, nur für mich. Wollen Sie mal reinhören? Warte mal hier. Die sind wahnsinnig. Warte mal. Nee, das ist richtig gut. Das ist richtig gut. Hier können sie mal reinhören. I don't want to we smell for the mountain way. I ghosted me for the wetness space. I'm water for rain. Someday on the sea. And above the bay. Das haben die nur für mich geschrieben.
Mega Song, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, dankeschön.
War das mal eine Frau im Hintergrund, die geschrieben hat eigentlich?
Ja, ich glaube, die war da auch dabei. Sehr musikalische Frau. Ganz toll. Ganz, ganz toll. Ganz, ganz toll.
Haben Sie noch einen zweiten Song?
Der ist noch ein bisschen roher, aber wir können gerne mal reinhören.
Die Ballade. outside and I'm gonna be so safe so snakes snakes so ja wie gesagt, der ist noch ein bisschen roh, okay, der hat mir nicht so gefallen, Snake Song ich finde, man kann schon sehen, in welche Richtung das geht. So, also, nochmal zurück zu den Neutronenrobotern. Sie haben mir in Ihrem Forschungsinstitut einiges geleistet. Machen wir es so, Sie geben mir die Roboter und Sie kriegen Ihre Frau zurück. Okay, alles klar. Gut. We have a deal. Jetzt kommt jetzt erst der heiße Tee leider. Wenn man eigentlich im Begriff war zu gehen, kommen jetzt gerade die heißen Teetassen. Das war wie bei dem Date, was ich mal hatte. Wo du so einen riesigen Kanister Tee hattest. Wo das Gespräch ausgeflattert ist und ich dann noch so einen Höflichkeitsdrink dann noch nehmen musste und dann kam halt eine riesen zwei Liter Kanne Tee. Riesiges Käsefondue. Riesiger Topf. Mit Brot und Weintrauben und Gurken und Paprika und alles. Das finde ich auch immer. Innerlich habe ich mich kaputt gedacht. Aber nach außen hin versteinerte mich. Noch nie hat jemand das Käsespezial so traurig und deprimiert gegessen. Normalerweise freuen die Leute sich da seit Wochen drauf. Ach ja, nee, nee. Eisbecher mit Wunderker, einfach so. Hast du mal Geburtstag
gefeiert in einem Restaurant, wo du Geburtstag hattest
und dann kamen so ganz viele
Wunderkerzen an?
Nee. Nie.
Immer unangenehm, man will nicht so sehr
im Mittelpunkt stehen. Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Überhaupt nicht. Ich glaube, deswegen ist es auch ein gängiger
Prank, dass man Leuten sagt, er hat heute Geburtstag
in einem Restaurant, damit dann
der Clown kommt, der Geige spielt und so, aber hat einfach nicht.
Okay, McDonalds, wo Ronald McDonald mit der Geige reinkommt. Das weiss ich noch, das waren die coolen Kinder bei uns, die früher bei McDonalds Geburtstag gefeiert haben, wo man sich selber einen Burger machen konnte, wo ich gesagt hätte, mach doch einfach nur ganz oft Fleisch und Käse. Ich habe jetzt eine Freundin von mir, hat ganz kleine Neffen und die verhindert es irgendwie Geburtstag, einer von denen und der Kindergeburtstag ist von 10 bis 13 Uhr. Und ich dachte mir, das sind Zeiten, ey. Und ich so, der spezielle Geburtstag oder sind generell Kindergeburtstage 10 bis 13 Uhr? Kindergeburtstage sind wohl einfach von 10 bis 13 Uhr. Aber das wäre für mich das Beste, zu wissen, ich gehe auf eine Party und da steht ein Endzeitpunkt fest. 10 bis 13 Uhr. Du hast eine Einladung für 10 bis 13 Uhr, da würde ich sofort hingehen, weil du einfach weißt, drei Stunden halte ich aus und dann gehe ich nach Hause. Und noch besser, du wirst abgeholt um 10 bis 13 Uhr. Da ist ja keine Diskussion, dass jemand länger bleibt oder kürzer bleibt. Wollen wir noch was trinken? Ne, meine Mutter ist hier. Meine Mutter ist schon da. Grossartig. Das finde ich super. Das sollte man, finde ich, auch bei allen Partys und Empfängen und generell machen. Einfach schreiben Endzeitpunkt. Auch hier ist wieder diese gauschische Glocke, weil nämlich ein sehr alter Nachbar von mir, wirklich schon so über 80, 85 sowas, der hat jetzt auch Geburtstag gefeiert und die an den Hand der Autos, die in der Einfahrt dann standen, habe ich gesehen, auch. Neun Uhr dreißig, war lächerlich früh, auch irgendwie so acht Uhr dreißig, neun Uhr dreißig, haben sie am Samstag, Sonntag bis zwölf Uhr dreißig, dann sind die alle wieder gefahren. Super. Und dann dachte ich mir, super, Frühstück, auch toll. Ja, mega gut, du hast den ganzen Tag noch für dich. Ja, man hat sowas so, wenn man was so besprechen, also am Frühstückstisch da ist immer, ne, und zur Not ist es, gib mir mal die Butter, gib mir mal den Frischkäse. Ja, es ist wirklich fantastisch. Und da fand ich, weil es 10-13 Kindergeburt war und Thema ist Ninja, eine Ninja-Prüfung oder sowas.
Fand ich auch nicht schlecht, also ein Motto da drin zu haben.
Und das hat mich an meine coolsten Kindergeburtstage erinnert, wo die immer ein Thema hatten.
Ich weiß noch, der coolste Kindergeburtstag, den ich jemals hatte, das war Mittelalter-themed.
Und wir hatten so einen Garagendurchgang zum Garten und mein Vater hat dann die Garage vorne, das so getan, als wäre es eine Burg, so eine Zugbrücke und hat das dann so verkleidet und selber gebastelt und so und drüber stand irgendwie zur Burg Tietze oder sowas, irgendwas Unangenehmes und dann der ganze Garten war mit so Mittelalter gedönst und jeder konnte sich ein Schwert nehmen, aufeinander einüche, das war der beste Geburtstag, und dann gab es auf einmal so eine große Schnitzeljagd und so, also das finde ich ja geil. Und bei diesem Ninja-Ding wäre ich jetzt nicht als Vater nicht tief genug im Thema drin, um jetzt diesen ganzen... Ja, da muss man sich anlesen, da muss man Was ist was Ninja irgendwie schon mal gucken, also die Frage ist ja, ist es was Spezielles, ist dann dieses Ninjago oder sowas von Lego, wo dann noch so dieses Mystische mit reinkommt mit Zauberkräften und Drachen und so, oder ist es Klassik, straight, ähm, irgendwie Fists of, nee, Tiger and Dragon Ninja-Kram rumspringen und sowas? Fist of God. Und natürlich, die Besten sind natürlich die, die gar nicht auftauchen und sagen so, ja, ihr habt mich nicht gesehen, ich bin der beste Ninja oder so, Vielleicht auch nicht schlecht. Und dann natürlich Wurfstern. Mikey, warum bist du nicht zum Geburtstag gekommen? Ich war doch da, ich war nur in den Schatten. Was? Aber ich finde, ich glaube, wenn ich Kinder hätte, ich würde da schon von den Themen her so versuchen, so ein bisschen Variation reinbringen. Nicht immer Mittelalter und Ninja, sondern ich würde irgendwie so Roaring Twenties oder irgendwie Wirtschaftskrise mit reinbringen. Nicht mit so St. Pauli, Kiez, irgendwie alle müssen so als Zuhälter oder Nutten kommen.
Okay.
Sowas.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Also noch mal, Herr Dietze, wegen der Einladung.
Sie schreiben drauf, meine Tochter soll als Nutte kommen. Nutte oder Zuhälterin, das ist ja egal. Okay, dann eher Zuhälterin, also ... Ja, also wie gesagt, das ist offen. Okay, zu trinken habe ich mehr die coolen Drinks. Gut, ja vielleicht kann die Annette nicht. Schade, der kleine Mike würde sich da freuen. Okay, wir überlegen mal. Im ganzen Garten habe ich so Polstangen aufgestellt. Aber einfach mal so ein bisschen out of the box, nicht immer die klassischen Themen, sondern dann einfach mal auch wirklich was Politisches oder so Badermeynhoff-Komplex oder so. G20 nachspielen. Jeder muss als ein Land kommen. Tschernobyl, einfach, dass man wirklich, also diese Sicherheitsanzüge irgendwie, wo man einfach sagt, immer ein bisschen Geschichte hautnah erleben. Das finde ich aber eigentlich ganz cool. In Dortmund gibt es dieses ganz tolle Museum DASA, die Deutsche Arbeitsschutzausstellung, was so das The Most German and The Most Dortmund Thing auf einmal ist, weil da gibt es halt nicht viel, außer Arbeiterkultur und deswegen deutsche Arbeitsschutzausstellung. Klingt unglaublich langweilig, ist aber ein unglaublich tolles Erlebnismuseum, wo auch so ein großes Kraftwerk, also so ein Atomkraftwerk, das Innere, also alle Schalter, die es im Atomkraftwerk gibt, gibt es da auch. Also kennt man ja die Szenen jetzt aus Tschernobyl, der HBO-Serie, fantastisch, wo man dann auch ab und zu in diesem Kontrollraum ist. Und das ist ja eine riesen Wand mit Schaltern und davor noch mal so eine Arbeitstheke, Konsole, wo man dann auch noch mal arbeiten kann. Und die haben halt alle Knöpfe nachgebaut, vielleicht sogar aus einem alten Atomkraftwerk einfach übernommen. Und da kann man sich dann hinstellen und alle Knöpfe drücken und so und Dinge beobachten. Und als Kind dann stehen halt ganz viele drei bis achtjährige davor, die halt das nicht zu schätzen wissen. Und so stelle ich mir diesen Geburtstag auch vor, die wissen nicht, was das ist. Die wissen nicht, warum das spannend ist. Die stehen einfach vor und drücken halt alle Knöpfe und dann wollen sie gehen. Aber ich als Erwachsener finde es dann mehr. Aber du konntest dann wirklich auch so Kernschmelze auslösen, wenn du das dann alles irgendwie falsch gemacht hast und so? Ja, du konntest auf jeden Fall auf so einen Alarmknopf drücken, dann ist das ganze Licht rausgegangen auch und dann kam so ein ... Mega gut. Das war richtig geil. Ich will da meinen Geburtstag feiern. Ja, da habe ich auch bestimmt meinen Geburtstag gefeiert. Das fand ich super cool. Und es gab eine Geisterbahn und die Geisterbahn war quasi auch Arbeitsschutz gethemed. Okay, keine leichte Aufgabe. Nee, aber total toll gelöst. Fässer wurden nicht richtig gelagert. Man ist durch einen Lagerraum, wo nicht richtig gelagert wurde. Und deswegen hast du so ein Near-Misses, wie man sagt. Die Fässer rollen auf dich ab und dann kurz vor, die bremsen die dann noch. Aber danach kommt man raus und denkt, ich muss Arbeitsschutz ein bisschen wörtlicher nehmen. Ich muss meine Fässer sichern, verdammt nochmal. Du Mama, wenn wir zu Hause sind, ich muss erstmal alle meine Fässer sichern, das ist wichtig. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum so viele Kinder rumlaufen, die verstehen das alles nicht. Wie es ist eine lame Geisterbahn, wo sehr viele Arbeitsschutz-Missgeschicke passieren. Aber so eine Arbeitsschutz-Themed Geburtstagsparty ist schon nicht ganz geil. Das, glaube ich, ist schon wirklich gut. Ja, da gibt es eine schöne Sicherheitseinweisung und dann nochmal alles in den Routinecheck, nochmal schön am Getriebe. Aber ich mochte das, kennt man ja manchmal aus Filmen, wo die so Planspiele machen in, oft in Highschools und dann will ich die G20 nachspielen und da muss jeder als sein Land vorbereitet, als Botschafter dann da hinkommen und dann wird gesprochen. Geopolitisch gesprochen. Und das finde ich auch gut. Jedes Kind kriegt so ein Dossier, die Geschichte von Bangladesch und dann einfach wirklich so muss man richtig pauken und dann kommt man da wirklich zusammen und dann wird einfach verhandelt. Ja, vielleicht wird auch abgebrochen für die Verhandlungen. Kann auch sein. Kann auch sein. Wenn es Mittagessen gibt, wird abgebrochen. Die Torte angeschnitten wird, wird abgebrochen. Ne, finde ich gut, aber ich finde eh, dass irgendwie diese Themes, wir brauchen neue Themes, weil warum sind es genau die so?
Es gibt immer Ägypten, Cowboy,
Ritter, Vampir,
wir müssen das nochmal neu durchmischen, so einfach,
wir brauchen irgendwie neue Bilder, neue
neue Wikinger, irgendwie so neue Archetypen,
wir müssen neu denken.
Gibt es schon viel, aber ne?
Du hast jetzt schon sehr viel aufgezeigt. Ja, aber
schau mal auf die gesamte Menschheitsgeschichte, wie viele
Sachen es da gab und wie wenig
davon archetypisch wirklich verarbeitet wird.
Ja, Mongolei ist es auch nicht. Was ist denn mit so einem ordentlichen
Vielen Dank. Das wird schon sehr viel aufgezeigt. Ja, aber schau mal auf die gesamte Menschheitsgeschichte, wie viele Sachen es da gab. Und wie wenig davon archetypisch wirklich verarbeitet wird. Ja, Mongolei ist auch nicht... Was ist denn mit so einem ordentlichen Freischerler? So einem ordentlichen vierzigjährigen Kriegtyp? Mit so einem Federhut und so bunten Hosen und so einer Akebuse in der Hand. So einem richtig grossen Gewehr. So einem richtig grossenen altertümlichen Gewehr mit so einem Stabstativ. Was ist denn
mit dem? Oder einfach so
Genghis Khan, einfach Mongolei. Ja, was ist denn mit
Genghis Khan?
Ja,
weil es halt immer so dazwischen ist.
Ich glaube, die, die man sich erwählt hat,
die haben so die klarsten Kostüme.
Ja, das ist halt die
YMCA, diese vier Leute, die halt einfach da was gesetzt haben. Die halt Bauarbeiter, Polizist, Häuptling. Und wo steht das A? Und Arbeitsschutz. Was noch? Bauarbeiter, Polizist, Häuptling? Ä. Feuerwehrmann. Arzt, Anwalt, Notar. Ich weiss es gar nicht. Es ist auch nicht so wild. Es ist nicht so schlimm, dass sie nicht drauf kommen. Dass die in Vergessenheit, hätte ich als Kind nie gedacht, dass die mal in Vergessenheit geraten. Die YMCA-Boys. Aber waren sie schon ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten, als es nur noch klein war. Aber wo man sich einfach denkt, Dinge sind, manche Dinge sind einfach nicht für immer, andere schon. So, ich könnte mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendwie Bruno Mars in Vergessenheit gerät. Aber in 50 Jahren, vielleicht weiss niemand mehr, wer das ist? Weisst du, was niemals in Vergessenheit gerät? Das Podcast-Ofo. Weiss ich nicht. Ganz ehrlich zu sein, bin ich mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Das heisst nicht, warum du diese tolle Moderation unterbrechst. Nee, aber einfach, da bin ich mir wirklich nicht sicher. Warum? Weil du jetzt sonntags nicht schläfst neuerdings mehr. Weil wir auch einfach nicht genug Sticker platziert haben. Wir sind nicht omnipräsent. Nee, wir sind so semi-präsent. Wir sind halt so semi-durchsichtig. 30 Prozent transparent sind wir.
Ja.
Ich fühle mich in meinem Leben so
20 Prozent transparent.
Also du bist fast
komplett durchsichtig. Ne, ne, ne.
80 Prozent der Kraft.
80 Prozent der Kraft, okay, alles klar. So fühle ich mich.
Okay. Ich werde schon gesehen,
aber halt manchmal nicht. Okay.
Bei starkem Gegenlicht nicht. Aber ist es nicht der perfekte Zustand, dass du manchmal auch sagen kannst, so wo ich mich hinstelle? Gerade vor sehr grellen Oberflächen kann man so einfach schön durchsichtig werden? Vor sehr grellen Menschen gehe ich unter. Das stimmt. Du umgibst dich auch manchmal bewusst mit grellen Menschen, einfach um ein bisschen unterzugehen. Ja, um mich so ein bisschen zu tarnen. Ja. Aber bei sehr blassen Menschen wiederum bin ich zu richtig raus. 80 Prozent Deckkraft. Es ist alles eine Frage des Kontrastes. Es ist alles eine Frage des Kontrastes. Ja, die Frage ist, seid ihr ein Streichelzoo? Und wenn ja, seid ihr im Disneyland Streichelzoo oder seid ihr im Zoo ein Streichelzoo? Es ist immer eine Frage der Perspektive. Genau. Wer wollt ihr sein? Es ist nicht schlimm, im Streichelzoo zu sein. Denn im Zoo seid ihr eine richtig coole Attraktion, seitdem Disneyland seid es nicht. Also, was ist die schwierige Lektion daraus? Zieht in eine scheiss Kack statt, umgebt euch mit furchtbaren Menschen. Umgebt euch mit langweiligen Menschen und ihr seid schon interessanter. Echt, das ist jetzt die Lösung? Ich glaube, das ist die Moral. Man hat ja selber nicht die Moral oft in der Hand. Am Ende des Märchens sagt man, das ist jetzt die Moral? Okay. Das ist aber jetzt nicht so schön. Sorry, es war nicht geplant, aber damit müssen wir jetzt ... Also wir können natürlich noch mal rumrudern. Aber ist es so, dass also bei deinem Traum, glaubst du, so entstehen auch Drehbücher oder Geschichten? Kann sein, kann sein. Karl May hat sich ja auch überlegt, ich kann nicht schlafen, so das machen wir mit einem Cowboy-Indianer. Was passiert da? Was passiert da? Hat er auch so wachgelegen wie du? Ja, kann schon sein, ich weiss nicht, ob da ein toller Roman draus wird am Ende, ob ich das mal alles niederschreibe. Im Grunde ist es ja auch egal, ob es wirklich passiert ist oder nicht. Du kannst ja auch als Hochstapler einfach auftauchen mit einem langen Bart und nassen Haaren und sagen, ich war wochenlang auf einer einsamen Insel. Will da jemand deine ... Es gibt ja keine Beweise. Du hast hier einen Ausweis. Ja, hier, hier ist mein Ausweis. Ich bin keine Ratte. Nur, dass es klargestellt ist. Komisch, dass Sie es sagen, aber ja, sehe ich. Das ist ein altes Foto. Da hatte ich noch keine Zahnspange. Die Zähne sind noch ein bisschen. Und Sie behaupten, Sie waren jetzt zwei Wochen auf einer einsamen Insel? Nee, vier Wochen, mindestens. Man verliert die Zeit. Und es war echt eine wilde Geschichte, mein ganzes Flugzeug ist abgestürzt, oder ich bin aus dem Flugzeug gefallen. Ich habe gar nicht gehört, dass ein Flugzeug abgestürzt ist. Da muss es schon echt lange her gewesen sein. Wann ist denn das letzte Flugzeug abgestürzt? 1973. Wow, so lange war ich unter, das ist schon krass. Das ist echt beeindruckend. Ja, man vergisst die Zeit, wenn du den ganzen Tag krabbelst. Wo sind Sie wieder hierher gekommen, nach Köln? Ja, ich wurde dann gerettet von so einem Tankerschiff und dann habe ich in so einem Container gelebt. Wie ist das Tankschiff zur Insel gekommen? Er wird ja flacher irgendwann. Ja, die haben dann so ein Boot, in den letzten Metern haben die noch so ein Boot gestiegen, da bin ich dann rein und dann sagen die jetzt, wo willst du wohnen, da habe ich mir einen von diesen Containern ausgesucht und dann wurde ich verladen tatsächlich, in Hamburg wurde ich verladen und tatsächlich war ich in so einem grossen Container mit so FC Kölle Anstecknadeln.
Abertausende, Abertausende, Abertausende FC-Kölle Anstecknadeln. Und dann wurde ich verschifft, kam auf den Lastwagen, bin nach Köln gefahren und jetzt bin ich hier. Ja, das ist eine wasserrichtige Geschichte. Alles klar. Vielen Dank, dass Sie es hier erzählt haben. Kann ich ein Buch schreiben? Vielen Dank, dass Sie es hier erzählt haben, bei Antenne Köln. Gerne. Und jetzt haben Sie noch einen Song. Jetzt wollen Sie noch einen Song vorstellen.
Ja, genau. Also einer meiner
absoluten Lieblingssongs ist
von The Prodigy.
Yellow Submarine
von Prodigy.
Alle Enden einfangen.
Yellow Submarine von Prodigy
gefällt mir richtig gut.
Wie kommen die immer nur auf diese Songs?
Ich weiss es nicht. Wo haben die das her? Moment mal, die Band The Prodigy gibt es überhaupt nicht. Oh. Moment mal kurz, in diesem Universum gibt es die Band The Prodigy überhaupt nicht. Dann lassen Sie mich kurz meine Gitarre holen. Snake soul
don't let me down
put your snake
down and
make it better
put your snake down
and make it better
put your fuck
put that fucking snake down, mister
why do
you have a snake put the snake down, mister. Why do you have a snake? Put the snake down and make it better. Remember, a snake is not a toy. Put the snake down and make it better, better, better, better, better, better La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la eins von fünf Spannung. Aber woanders hin, also nicht, dass jetzt irgendwie hunderte Leute versuchen, Bücher zu schreiben über einsame Inseln.
Macht das nicht. Ciao. Das wäre super lame.
Wir hemen ab und schützen auf den Jablo.
Ciao.
It's a worst bird production.